[Music]
we have Daniel naroditsky's top five
brilliant moves that man is brilliant we
all know Donya commentator Legend half
man half everything else Daniel
nerdinsky this is number five this one
is against Grandmaster Dimitri kolars
out of Germany let's get right into it
Daniel raditzki's plain white of course
what happened in this position was E4 E4
attacking the Knight the Knight is
hanging first off what's going on we got
double Rooks of course there's some
problems here with the King if you move
the Rook Rook takes B2 it's kinda shaky
it's double edged what is actually going
on you also have a pin going on but you
can't really use it yet because The
Bishop's defending the g-pawn right now
the knight's hanging what does uh Daniel
do Knight E5 he attacks the queen pretty
easy move to make of course the engine
doesn't like it as much they like Knight
G5 because of a sequence of Moves In
Black can play which is Queen to D6
attacking the Knight the Knight is
actually hanging the pawns actually
hanging as well pretty easy move to find
next which is D4 defending the Knight
the Knight is now defended of course we
don't have to worry about any checks or
any problems like that and the move here
is supposed to be Rook takes F6 now
Queen takes F6 is the move that was
played in the game and it looks totally
fine but it's a double question mark
move it is right to move here when did
Daniel nerdinski play in this position
hopefully you pause the video hopefully
you really tried to figure this one out
okay the move here is and it's brilliant
by the way
are you ready for this
five
four three one what takes G6 oh my
goodness there it is it's on the board
hopefully you saw that wow Rook takes G6
what a move
what a move now of course the queen is
hanging what are you doing what are you
doing bro your queen is hanging if he
takes the queen well that's very mean
get this off the screen after Rook G8
check Rook takes and then Knight F7 is
made because of the other Rook stopping
the king from moving and the king is in
check due to Knight F7 beautiful
Checkmate once again that is nasty there
hopefully you're doing your puzzle Rush
Queen takes H4 runs into Rook G8 Rook
takes Knight F7 is Checkmate start a new
game beautiful okay so he saw this
Rook takes G6 boom that happened now of
course Dimitri goes with hey I see that
that's cute that's fun oh that was nice
Dania nice trick Rook takes B2 was check
right King has to move back because if
you block the connection you end up
losing a rook also the mate's not there
anymore so we actually go King H1 and
then Queen takes E5 that's a very very
sharp move very cool stuff right Queen
takes E5 of course the problem here is
of course Rook G8 once again the Queen's
also hanging where do you even move the
queen comfortably you really don't have
a move it just says best move is take
the Rook he chose taking the night Queen
takes Knight okay cool hopefully we have
something here says black d takes E5
taking back the Queen B uh Bishop takes
rook and Rook takes bishop and that was
it the game was over the game could have
continued here for with Rook B1 and uh
Rook to G1 to defend it and he's just up
a queen here this was nasty let's go
back and look at that one more time for
the people in the back that miss that of
course it started from here and we have
95 getting out of danger attacking the
queen queen goes to D6 to pin the Knight
also attacking the pawn easy move
defended Queen takes F6 trying to trade
but leaving oh I'm fine yeah let's
release this pressure that you have
because looks kind of annoying and then
Daniel nerdinski says I got you a big
fella Rook takes G6 get him off the
board that's a nasty one because again
after you take the queen Rook GA is mate
I'm also attacking the queen if you take
the bishop here in fact it's actually
look at that if you take the bishop here
we have an easy move Knight takes G6
ouch Knight takes G6 here of course if
Queen takes we take with the root we can
also come back and block as well if you
move the king anywhere King GA King G7
King anything we're gonna take this Rook
with check it's going to be decisive
results kg is actually going to lose to
losing the queen in many cases here so
pretty stuffed up pretty stuff pretty
tough stuff here in fact the engine says
uh best movies Queen takes G6 but this
was number five out of the five and
we're gonna go over brilliant moves
let's look at number four here we are
with brilliant move and number four from
Daniel nerdinski and this time he's
facing yaspo everybody knows him that's
Jose Martinez very very strong player as
you see he's 30 90 when he was playing
this game against Daniel so a last move
here was G6 from
um from uh adjust from here after G6
hitting the bishop we move the bishop
away pretty easy move Bishop to G4 Pawn
structure is kind of strange for black
we do have a nice Pawn on E5 we need to
complete development Rooks are
disconnected there is some pressure down
the f file also with maybe even some
sacrifices here on F2 trying to uh to
use the fact that we do have the Rook on
the app file maybe trying to use the app
file as much as we can so of course
black actually play makes a move Queen
E7 defends G5 because that actually is
hanging in the last move here that X is
a pawn that can be captured so defended
connecting my Rooks at the same time a
very easy move we need to have all of
our pieces in the game so this next move
makes total sense from Daniel playing
Bishop to D2 connect my Rooks I have not
moved it how do I improve my position
moving forward my Bishop is better on D2
than it was on C1 and my Rook can
finally get into the game now here we go
from Yasmin plays 986 very logical here
attacking the bishop if you move this
bishop I'm going to play G4 so you may
make a move like H3 right or move the
Knight to defend the bishop on G4 well
that's actually up to you chat it's on
you what do you do in this position in
fact what If Daniel nerdinski play in
this position white to move
here it is guys of course here the best
defense is offense so we take our Queen
and we go to A6
psych this is a family channel okay the
move here is Bishop E6
this is the move Bishop E6 that's the
offense we were looking for there that's
a wild move of course you're gonna get
these from Daniel neradinsky right of
course a tactician very strong player we
know this a magician if you will Bishop
takes E6 so takes a free Pawn of course
and we say free well I mean he can just
take the bishop which he does Queen
takes E6 well this is now the move for
the follow-up or the follow-up for the
move it's white to move what do you do
in this position we just gave up this
bishop for the pawn are we gonna play
Knight to G5
Bishop G5 right right what is it that's
why it's a move what do you do
okay so nothing goes to G5 here that's
going to be a blunder get it off the
screen but the move that does work and
it's brilliant is Queen takes A4 sack
the queen
sack the Queen the whole thing Queen
takes E4 Daniel radissy says if I sack
I'ma get it right back just like that
after d takes E4 Knight takes G5 and we
live ex decisive results move the key
Knight takes E6 and we're looking good
here we should be able to convert this
of course to Rooks hanging but also the
knights hanging yeah okay you can go
rookie eight and take my knight I'll
take your Bishop but this in-game is
definitely winning especially with um
the problems in the pawn structure or
especially the break here in Pawn
structure and white having actually an
extra Pawn there at least two for the
time being is this one might be gone but
with that being said this did not happen
in fact what did happen in the game was
after Bishop takes E6 Queen takes E6
Queen takes E4 Rook to F5 and of course
Daniel radicchi near Disney after moving
his Queen Once good was able to go on to
convert this game but of course going
back here this is the part that was
brilliant this is the part we wanted to
highlight was well I'm starting from
here
after 96 attacking the bishop he moves
it to E6 Bishop takes E6 attacking The
Rook taking the pawn queen takes E6 and
then boom we just want a pawn out of
that and your structure is garbage here
it's absolutely terrible structure your
king safety is worse than mine I have a
pass Pawn I'm doing good as white this
was number four
now let's move on to number three here
we go guys with number three from near
Disney in the five brilliant moves from
Daniel nerdinski this is the third one
in this one he's actually facing lonely
Queen Grand Master here with the black
pieces um playing lonely Queen is
playing black and danielsky's playing
white in this position right here let's
actually see what happened this looks
like some type of Scandinavian Carol
Khan with an early H5 believe it or not
it was actually an H3 move one
opening here and then um H5 move two
opening here so very strange but we
reached this position with this looks
like some type of Scandinavian or Carol
Khan uh s here uh some something like
that right with the inclusions of H3 and
H5 which is very possible some type of
like you know you would see the Tau
variations but that's like H4 but okay
H3 trying to play G4 you can see this
right not H3 and H5 move one never would
have thought that would have came from
this opening but nevertheless here we go
of course the last move was Queen to C7
from Lonely Queen and near Disney makes
a very easy move Rook E1 this reminds me
a lot of the Scandinavian positions in
fact Wesley so has some very nice files
on how to really crush the Scandinavian
here and this reminds me of that the
reason being is because after Rook to E1
we have the 96 you have Knight F7 you
have rookie six you have all this stuff
coming like right here on E6 and F7
these squares are very soft especially
with the king and the center
nevertheless of course black says okay
you know what you're not really
threatening anything just yet so I'm
gonna kick you away B5 hits the bishop
makes logical since attacked the bishop
police trade or go back to B3 but at
least I get some space I can now think
out of the bishop I may even go Queen
side because I didn't make H5 as a move
here both sides of the board are pretty
rough for the king but I'd rather Castle
maybe where some pieces are so after B5
Bishop to D3 right just I in this way
saying yeah if you Castle this way you
might as well hit the button resign on
the spot right because there's got to be
something here I mean of course it looks
very deceiving in chess here but uh and
calculation is very important make sure
you calculate but I mean casting looks
really crazy right so Bishop to D3 black
did not Castle here only Queen chose
Bishop to B7 but this one gets them sent
to Heaven immediately white to move what
is the move here digital was able to
find it this combination is so sick it's
white to move what do you do in this
position
okay here it is so first move from
Daniel aradiski is we pick it up
and we put it down Route 1066 hitting
splitting hitting splitting Rook takes
E6 yeah you see this all the time in the
Scandinavian and uh you'll see this in
Sicilians in fact when you sacrifice
something on E6 and Knight dwarfs shows
and variations of the Sicilians right I
mean this is very important to
understand and sacrificing on E6 well
what's the key what's the idea of course
if he ever takes his Rook here well then
we go Bishop G6 check and it's a wrap
you could also start with Knight E6 this
is beautiful Bishop G6 if king f8 or d8
anything eight we're just gonna hit him
on E6 and that's going to be nasty right
we pick up the queen
um no matter where he goes pretty pretty
pretty nasty stuff there or you can even
do Knight E6 first which is even cooler
if the engine likes this better but
after the queen moves I mean that's
pretty nasty mate Bishop G6 may get him
off the board gross so uh let's
Checkmate Rook takes E6 happen so his
opponent says oh you're not about to hit
me like that so he steps out the way
with King to f8 after the king f8 okay
what do we do in this position right
here after King f8 where do you think
you go right now what do you think you
got to campaign
right to move
increase the pressure
that's how I help you here you know
pause the video if you need to come back
because I can understand if you don't
find a move here it's not easy to find
like to move it either
here we go
and the move is
Queen E2 very simple because for some
people are not expecting that they're
expecting like holding your breath like
it's no it's not it's just Queenie too
very simple move increase to pressure
we're not going to take twice right so
what's the idea what's the idea Black's
like yeah I don't know what your idea is
so C5 and you thought Rook E6 was nice
you thought Rook E6 was the the most
brilliant thing ever which of course
okay we gave it to him yes it was great
but if you thought that was brilliant
watch this next sequence of moves why to
move what do you do
I hope you brought the towel hat right
now what does towel say shout out to
grandfather's house grandfather towel
says sack first think later that's what
they he taught us back in the day here
it is 1977
oh my goodness wait what stop okay hold
up 197 so we sacked on E6 then we sack
on F7 this doesn't make any sense are we
gonna play Knight G5 right
why would we do this because he could
just take it King takes F7 this doesn't
make any sense to me Knight G5 is a
terrible move I'm just gonna take it
what are you doing Bishop G6 I'm gonna
move the king back to f8 it doesn't work
unless you find this move as well Rook
takes C7 I'm done
foreign
Rook takes E7 after Knight takes E7 now
we go Knight G5 and you can resign right
here you can hit the button like hey oh
my goodness this is beautiful this is
this is probably the sick it's one of
the sickest combinations out there right
now if you see Rook takes E6 is
absolutely brilliant of course as you
know why you can't take it show I
sidestep queen E2 increase the pressure
with the idea of sacking everything okay
C5 Knight takes F Sound king takes draw
the king out Rook takes E7 after Knight
takes E7 this is why Queen E2 is
important you can't take with the queen
or the King after Knight takes E7 then
we play Knight G5 check and that's a
resi hit the button my guy if King E8
Bishop G6 is check right let's just
throw it up here boom 96 is going to be
nasty once again if you go King to G8 we
go Queen E6 come on now right this is a
family channel and then after King has
eight night night check here if you go
King like where do you put the king oh
nowhere
oh
yeah you don't have any squares really
so with that being said the game was
over after Knight G5 check and this was
a wrap it was a resignation there then
you're near Disney clinical Precision
magician that was nasty that was number
three let's move to number two here we
go guys with number two this is near
ditsky playing with the black pieces
against Andrew Tang penguin GM a very
strong one of course this one is
actually uh King's Indian defense as we
know
um they're just he's a specialist there
he loves the king's Indian plays very
very great aggressive attacking chess
you can see from his King's Indians here
and here we go now last move this was a
samish variation with the early F3
casting on opposite sides here so we
know stuff's getting crazy looks like
Daniel was able to get some type of King
side attack very quickly after King to
be what being the last move Bishop E6
from near diski which is putting
pressure and you see the Bishops like
swiping the board here after Bishop E6
D5 from tang and after the D5 move it's
on you so it's black to move what do you
do in this position
foreign
take a look
lots of things going on
you know something's here you can smell
it in the water
here it is after the D5 move
Knight takes day five seconds of course
of course we sack it but she gotta have
the follow-up
to see the sack first chapter Knight
takes D5 we open up the bishop very very
nice
um diagonals for the bishop here but we
did sacrifice the whole piece so after
he takes D5 what is your follow-up what
is your follow-up come on what is it I
know you got it what is it because if
you saw that then you had to see the
follow-up right of course if you didn't
that's okay but work on seeing that
follow-up after he takes D5 they follow
up is Bishop to F5 check best moves
actually came to C1 if you go King A1
you're done right and that's a wrap but
King C1 was uh the better move and
followed by that would be Queen A4
believe it or not it's a very
complicated game still after Knight to
G3 and Rook takes E3 it's like
ridiculous right King C1 Queen A4 193
Rick takes with the idea of like Queen
here Knight takes F5 and then the engine
gives B3 bro let me just let's just go
back and what is actually going on here
there's this this is ridiculous right
there's so much going on but this didn't
happen Andrew saying with King A1 which
is actually very strange to go here but
I mean he was like well I am on the C
file like which way do we actually go I
mean this was actually the worst way
because it does run into the diagonal
here but now it is up to you what do you
do in this position right here it is
black to move what do you do right now
Queen's pin by the way so if you're
trying to get froggy here and just oh
take the pawn
yeah it would just you know lose a queen
maybe you take on E3
maybe you take on B2
maybe you develop a piece try to get the
Rook to be eight what's the plan what do
you do here
hopefully you did your puzzle rush in
your tactics because the move here is
sack the queen back of the Queen B takes
A3 what do you mean what you thought was
gonna play Knight D7 here come on you've
lost your mind B takes A3 after Queen
takes A5 it's made on the board Pawn or
the bishop your choice whatever you like
it's fate however you look at it it's
gonna be Checkmate but with a nasty
Bishop two Bishops in the pawn yikes
okay B takes A3 he's like I'm not
falling for that you're not about to get
me but I can't block it watch this
Knight E to C3 haha I gotcha right you
thought you got me well I got you big
fella well of course here's another sack
boom Rook takes E3 you didn't even see
that coming where did that even come
from you didn't even know the Rook was
right it didn't even feel like it was
right here right Rook takes E3 Queen
takes E3 a takes B2 right drawing the
king out and then a subtle move right
now it is minus seven
is minus seven we just subtle move can
you find it fine can you find it before
I make it very subtle move here very
very just uh
let's make this move yeah
let's do this right it's okay right
where are we going here black to move
very easy move to make
97 very calm move because you need to
get another piece everything is doing
what it's supposed to do queen doesn't
have any good checks just because you
see a check doesn't mean that you make
the check right Rook 2b8 is going to be
next right very strong you also can
increase the pressure by night to B6
with a knight A4 idea sometimes maybe
even 95 but this one does block the
bishop and you can't go to C4 just yet
but Knight to D7 Bishop to D3 blocking
some diagonals so I can highlight my
gain Rook to B8 King to C2 right after
King C2 there's a beautiful move 95. are
you like wait what we just blocked a bit
we just what is this
we just block the like the diagonal we
can't go Knight C4 he's about to take
line five
and he does he takes on F5 and now it's
up to you so you're like wait what do we
just do here why did Daniel play this
what is he doing what is he doing it's
black to move what do you do what is
Daniel doing
what do you do
oh oh you do your tactics and you make a
move like this rugby too and stare at
him real hard and uncomfortably
yeah look at that move right there Rook
B2 that's a move oh my goodness that is
a move for a move right if Kingston
takes B2 obviously Knight C4 check
because the bishop is now gone what what
a sick move Rook to B2 so came to C1 and
amen I mean the tactics here one of my
favorite players is Daniel raditzki of
course Hikaru Nakamura as well you got
for Russia you got tal and Carlson but
Queen A3 is nasty very strong move and a
resignation was here because I'm going
to have decisive results the king can't
move really anywhere anything I do is
with check this is crazy this is still
hanging here this is insane
I'm very sick very sick and of course
they always like to give you a line of
how something could continue and the
like would have continued like Rook D2
says this is best move takes King Rook
check and take on H1 F4 and Bishop H6
and this is what um what they would give
but there was a resignation here after
Queen A3 once again let's see that
Wicked attack one more time here this is
what happens in the king's Indian when
it really works King A1 he took on A3
very nice Queen's hanging because they
take it he's like no I'm not gonna do
that so Brook takes E3 okay cool bro
you're gonna have to take something I'm
gonna draw the king out takes takes on
B2 Knight D7 beautiful
Bishop D3 Rook V8 95 and you have to go
95 with the intention to know that you
were about to go Rook to B2 Next Level
chess here very brilliant from Donya
after uh night uh Bishop takes that five
Rook B2 King C1 Queen A3 in the game was
over whoa that was number two all right
guys let's move on to number one here we
are with the final one the brilliant
move number one here from Daniel
narodinski he's playing with the black
pieces against Brandon Jacobson Brando
we know him now of course this is a very
very crazy game after these next few
moves well let's see what happens in
this position here on white plays E4 so
of course very strong Pawn strong sensor
but the king is quite weak if you see on
the diagonals and the just the squares
around the king are extremely weak if we
can deal with this then we can win but
we can't we don't have any pawn breaks
or way to put pressure on the center
right now or at least this Pawn chain
um and the Central Pawn we would have to
play something like F5 or D5 F5 is
extremely risky and it takes a move to
do so and D5 we don't have a d Pawn so
the only way we can get anything going
is sacrifice in here but you need to
sacrifice at the right moment but of
course we need more pressure hence Rook
88 hey might be second are we maybe
maybe not he goes Rook to D2 and says I
dare you bro I don't believe in you now
the question is do you sack this or do
you not it is black to move in this
position what do you do do you sack on
e4 do we you know Bishop takes Knight
takes like or do we do Rook do we do it
or do or do we increase the pressure
maybe H5 Queen C6 G5 that's a crazy move
may you move the Knight go with that at
five idea what do we do in this position
is black to move
here it is near Disney says well Rook to
D2 you didn't believe me and when they
don't believe you that's when you do it
night tasting for whatever it is now of
course don't follow that at home because
it may be wrong make sure you
calculating over everything calculation
right Knight takes C4 is on the board
that's a big boy move from a big fella
Knight takes E4 of course I'm giving up
a whole piece for a pawn so F takes E4
happens he's like cool you do it once
I'll do it again Rick takes E4 if Knight
takes E4 I mean come on now Bishop takes
E4 and you can just hit the button hit
the that's the resign button that's what
that is Rook takes E4 so he steps out of
the way King H2 and you did your little
sack you know I mean you did your little
sack and thought she was all brilliant
and stuff even though this is your
brilliant moves video what are you
supposed to do now all right you down to
piece and I move my king out the way
what is this black to move what do you
do
well a lot of times one brilliant move
can be followed up with another Rook
takes F4 get that off the board bro get
it off of the board Rook takes that four
very strong move very very strong
getting rid of one of the Defenders of
the king G takes F4 had to be played but
the follow-up is the hard part here now
pause the video come back in a few
minutes if you really need to here this
one actually does take some calculation
and you have to figure out where you
want to put your queen what's the best
spot for it black to move what do you do
what do we do take your time here this
is not one that you just immediately
find and play if you find them all great
definitely do a little bit of
calculation too and some double checking
but the move here was in the best move
is Queen to F6 attacking both of these
Queen E3 actually doesn't work so if you
set queen E3 good looking good checking
but not the right move Queen F6 is a
double attack here very strong double
attack it also frees the E3 Square for a
rook if you need to sometimes if we need
to go somewhere right here so Rook to G2
defending all of the squares around the
king you can't even really defend this
too much it was Rook E3 by the way
coming especially if he wanted to play
like a king H3 so Rook to G2 giving some
material back but we don't need to take
this at all says Daniel nerdiskey Queen
takes H4 with check King to G1 and watch
this move right here this is precise
Precision the strongest bringing more
pieces into the game you learn something
every time you see moves like this it's
Rook to E3 what a nice move quiet very
quiet just rookie three and tell me
where do you go
what do you do next
what do you even do there's a threat of
Rook H3
Right Moving The Rook always runs into
weird stuff
you also have Rook G3 if you move the
Rook like what happened
I mean blacks down a whole Rook or are
they right this Rook is out of the game
if you put this Rook off the board
it would be like the same position
because this is how irrelevant The Rook
is if the Rook was active everything
would be different but it's not even
active and it's giving black so many
chances here after Rook E3 Queen F2
sounds it seems like you know very
logical move trade them off bro we gotta
get this stuff off the board yeah this
was fun and all but you got to get this
off the board Queen H3 from near Disney
after Queen H3 the move is Knight to D1
attacking The Rook pieces go backwards
it's a pretty good move right it attacks
The Rook but it's a pretty good move
unless you find this move right here
black to move finish it finish him what
do you do if his blast to move
go
here it is hopefully you were doing your
puzzle rest guys I'm gonna say easy one
Ricky won and he's done he resigns as
you see the flag but rookie one
um rookie one check after rookie one
king uh Queen takes E1 and queen G2
Checkmate is the idea if Queen F1 Queen
G2 really you can just have this on
pre-move
um Queen G2 is Checkmate basically no
matter what beautiful Brilliance in fact
if we go back and look at that one more
time Rook to D2 in fact here was where
it started E4
double the Rooks sick
sack sack again bring another piece in
the game
right check bring the rook in make sure
everything's ready to work Queen F2 no
trades for you my guy Knight to D1
rookie one and he's done brilliant
Precision tactics fun everything we
wanted to see um here in these games
today hopefully you guys enjoyed this
one this was awesome I had a great time
with you make sure you put your comments
in the chat of stuff that you like and
if you found some of the moves guys and
if you like this video then make sure
you check next ones as well and we'll
see you guys on the next video